[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
النجوم موجوده بالليل والنهار لكن قوه
شعاع الشمس تجعلنا لا نشاهدها نهارا فهي
مخفيه خلف شعاعها ولو خرجنا خارج الغلاف
الغازي لشاهدنا النجوم بشكل دائم على شكل
نقاط ليش لانه ما في نهار فالنهار صفه
ملازمه للارض ينتج عن تحوش شعاع الشمس الى
ضوء عن طريق الغلاف الغازي وايه لهم الليل
نسلخ منه النهار فاذا هم مظلمون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وكوكب الارض يوجد عليا ليل ونهار اذا طلعت
الشمس صار نهار واذا راحت الشمس صار ليل
والدول العربيه يتقارب فيها طول الليل مع
النهار والدول الاوروبيه الغلبه للنهار
هذا بصيف والغالبه لليل هذا بالشتاء وعلى
القطبين سته شهور نهار وسته شهور ليل
والنجوم لا تشاهدوا الا ليلا وحديد البصر
يقدر يشوف جرمين سماويين في حال النهار
هما كوكب المشتري وكوكب الزهره والعامه
يقولون والله لاوريكم نجوم القايله
ويقصدون بها كوكبي المشتري والزهره
والنجوم تبعد عنا بعدا سحيقا فاقرب نجم
الينا هو نجم الفا قنطوره يبعد عنا اربع
سنوات
ضوئيه وسنها الضوئيه الواحده هي المسافه
التي يقطعها الضوء وهو يسير بمسافه 300
الف كيلو متر
بالثانيه تخيل هذه المسافه والله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول فلا اقسم بمواقع النجوم وانه
لقسم لو تعلمون عظيم
[موسيقى]